posez votre question on vous trouve
l'info je veux pas être un oiseau de
malheur mais la pandémie
ça fait réfléchir s'il m'arrivait
quelque chose mon testament n'est pas à
jour on a souvent entendu qu'on peut
écrire ses dernières volontés soi même
même sur une serviette de table on
l'écrit de ça proprement
c'est ce qu'on appelle un testament
olographe ça ne coûte rien au besoin
d'aller chez le notaire
mais est-ce que c'est valide oui bonjour
m beauchamp nous prenons contact avec un
spécialiste michel bouchât un auteur
problèmes qu'on a de plus en plus en
vérification faite aux trouver quelqu'un
qui reconnaît l'écriture et finalement
c'est vrai que testament la grave c'est
valide mais il faut absolument le faire
vérifier et ça ça peut coûter jusqu'à
1500 $ selon notre expert et s'il faut
en plus s'assurer que l'écriture est
bien celle du défunt c'est encore plus
cher bref ce qu'on a voulu économiser
avant la succession veulent payer après
tandis qu'un testament notarié en
moyenne ça coûte entre 350 et 500
dollars
le prix peut varier de nanterre à
l'autre et non ce n'est pas donné mais
après votre décès c'est pas mal moins de
problèmes posés nous votre question on
vous trouve l'info partiellement